[Music]  I thought darkness but sensed it Billy  seen at moments during his training but  the mammoth inside and it was beyond  what I ever imagined  the potential of your blood  ooh  [Music]  for the briefest moment Puran stop it  I was the issue of consequence  [Music]  during his art he had three destruction  being in death at the end of everything  because what he would become  [Music]  balance alpha like a futon  I need someone to show me my place in  all this  [Music]  time to little things die  [Music]  I'm trattoria he said no no you're  stupid  [Music]  strike me down and anger and I'll always  be with you just like your father  I'm being torn apart  [Music]  don't want to be free of this pain leave  here with me come on we miss you  [Music]  you  you  [Music]